facebook under fire big time on multiple
fronts yesterday a massive outage froze
the site for more than six hours along
with instagram and whatsapp chances are
you noticed the company blames a
technical issue and today a
whistleblower is testifying before
congress francis hogan told 60 minutes
she believes that the company is
organized to put profit before safety
we'll have more on that in just a second
but first vladimir dutia has details of
that widespread outage glad good morning
and it lasted for several hours it did
indeed gail the problem appears to have
started around noon eastern time
yesterday when users started seeing
error messages popping up when they
tried to access their accounts the
outage lasted around six hours leaving
the company to issue apologies as it
were to get back online and restore
access to its billions of customers
if you logged onto facebook or any of
its popular properties like instagram or
whatsapp yesterday you waited
and waited the social media giant was
completely knocked offline for hours a
nightmare scenario for a company already
being criticized on multiple fronts the
massive global outage started after
facebook said that what it called
configuration changes on its routers
were the root of the issue disrupting
network traffic and bringing services to
a halt the cascading effects were
wide-ranging not only affecting users
but also many of facebook's internal
systems meaning its own employees were
unable to access the company's internal
messaging system or even gain access to
offices as their work badges stopped
working the outage even locked out
engineers working to fix the problem
remotely that's incredibly disruptive
chris krebs is a former director of the
cyber security and infrastructure
security agency he explains how the
problem prevented facebook systems from
communicating across the internet it's
kind of like in the old days when you've
got someone sitting at an operator board
plugging in
the lines to make calls connect and
effectively the operator lost all
understanding of where on the board they
were supposed to plug in krebs says
facebook's outage exposed how
interconnected its technology and its
billions of users are with the internet
economy as a whole facebook is also used
by some small businesses as their only
sort of internet platform
how problematic was it for them there's
a lot of business to business services
and functions that are enabled by
facebook and instagram you think about
all the advertisement the products that
are sold that really puts a disruption
across the ability of those companies to
tr to transact business now it's
important to note that facebook says no
user data was breached during the outage
the company and several high-profile
people at the organization apologized
yesterday for the impact the outage had
on its users technical issues like this
happen from time to time in fact
facebook had a similar incident happen
back in 2019 however experts say it is
extremely rare for so many internet
platforms to go down globally at the
same time nate feels like we're living
in the matrix where's morpheus when you
need them vlad thank you